scotland yard que es la policía
metropolitana de londres no dará
detalles ni revelará los nombres de las
20 personas que serán multadas en el
escándalo del partido sin embargo si el
primer ministro boris johnson hace parte
de este grupo entonces da un inscrito
así lo revelará lo cierto es que si
johnson es encontrado culpable y
entonces multado sería muy difícil y muy
complejo para su credibilidad y su
autoridad por ahora su futuro está en
manos de su partido el partido
conservador que se precia de ser un gran
respaldo para la policía y seguidor de
las leyes lo cierto es que en este
momento el johnson cuenta con el apoyo
de su partido pero este anuncio podría
desatar que se pierda la confianza en el
líder y muy poco probable que se
convoque a una moción de censura porque
ahora con la guerra en ucrania johnson
ha tratado de mostrarse como un líder
internacional
buscando la unidad de europa y de la
otan frente a rusia algunos analistas
con los que conversado aseguran que la
guerra en ucrania con todo el horror que
esto trae ha sido casi que un salvavidas
político para boris johnson que antes de
esta difícil situación tenía
prácticamente sus semanas contadas en
downing street lo cierto es que la
policía ha encontrado que durante el
confinamiento en el 2020 se cometieron
delitos ha encontrado culpables en
downing street de al menos 20 personas
investigó al menos 12 fiestas ilegales
que se habrían realizado en la sede del
gobierno y realizó investigaciones y
cuestionarios a más de 100 personas